[Music]
hello everybody what is up and welcome
to GameSpot live Persia here and giant
waffles in the building oh snap very
excited for today's stream because
today's stream is actually sponsored by
Playstation now and if you didn't know
PlayStation now lets you stream more
than 800 PlayStation games on your ps4
or your PC plus you can also download
any of the 300 plus ps4 games in the
surface directly to your ps4 you can
learn more at PS now.com and will give
you more details on that later but for
now I think we need to jump in to this
game we are playing infamous second son
and I've played it a little bit it's
pretty good and for a game that's kind
of been over a long time and if you
haven't played it I would definitely
recommend going back and checking it out
yeah I actually haven't played this one
yet but I happily the first one so I'm
actually really excited to kind of get
into this and see how it starts off
where it's going to go yeah
[Music]
intense music everyone this game that
came out people talked about it quite a
bit because you were saying you played a
lot of the first one yeah all right that
was up to y'all to read that yeah I read
that and thank you all for joining us
today
this takes place in Seattle right not
yet
[Music]
it is loud you guys lose oh right it's
so loud those tire is heavy [ __ ]
and this is just one of many games
that's gonna be featured places now yes
yes got a ton of games on there like
over 800 that's a lot
now this musics so good I remember this
[Music]
oh yeah let's deface some property
[Laughter]
all the stencil goodness trying to get
everything don't you
[Music]
this actually turns into like some of
the most therapeutic what am I missing
[Music]
cool yeah use like the tilt controls on
the controller the spray pants hey art
is a crime than just damnit nice hiding
is like you know coaching down salmon
Bay mmm party the longhouse just got to
get there mingle establish an alibi I'm
a goddamn criminal mastermind
does he believe this can of paint the
evidence fingerprints
who's out there it's just me Betty won't
put his stapler down seriously what are
you doing here why aren't you at the big
to do with the long house oh yeah I just
didn't feel all that a comas tonight
because you look really well
were you up to mischief okay but come on
seriously what are you gonna do here
well I have no choice
he's a cop I have to be back here in
five minutes and if you were still here
thanks Betty
this is the last time I have to go back
to my office apparently I'm getting a
phone call
can't have a good story without an
adorable old lady have anything better
to do who's like your BFF
this year hello freedom and the easy
part
get to the longhouse set up an alibi if
it's a Skelton and I'm done I'm
notoriously good at stealth yeah it's
pretty good it's pretty good
get extra parkour action
and for everybody in the global thanks
for joining us we are playing isn't a
second fun on PS now in case you're
wondering
no my powers in this game are super cool
agreed agreed
but no spoilers yet your first time
trying this one out and I kind of want
to see you like how you feel about it in
comparison to the first one yeah I'm
curious what they're gonna do with it I
never the first one being really unique
and I played it
I do think I have a soft spot for games
that make you choose this way like being
good and being evil what are you
typically choosing the situations oh
yeah I feel like that's normal I feel so
bad if they're like hey you go kill some
civilians like what I can't nature it's
cool Dave let you do both yeah shoo-shoo
maybe give you real benefits to choosing
either side like you only unlock certain
abilities or little or good which is a
little bit of you know some trying to do
skin some convincing to us
David mg says love this game respect
don't look down don't look down don't
look down
I wish I was a strong 12 I know that
everybody's worried hey man looking like
forever for you how about we just get
there soon it is for me to keep
arresting my own brother over and over
and over again you should stop arresting
your brother over and over in a joke no
I know you want to leave your mark on
the world huh you think this would make
our parents proud misdemeanor vandalism
sameen there's a lot of scary [ __ ] in
the world while I'm out there actually
trying to assert my talent rhinoceros
brain it's really because I don't seem
too greedy what truck
hope you guys read that intro I'm going
after those two you stay back that
thing's gonna blow
stay away from the exploding thing got
it is it fresh best so we gameplay it
was fun but they'll soon has a character
he's lame I completely disagree
I think Olson is oh these are much got a
lot in this one yeah just let him go and
keep your hands where I can see them
don't hurt nobody
I just wanna get go full she can't she
like said let him go or I will shoot you
right
your secrets it's got interesting real
fast
right
I gotta find Reggie okay how was that
what the hell since I like him so relate
to me this oh yes how is this relatable
in any fashion
if I got these powers I'd be like what
the hell do I wouldn't be like oh my
gosh like fire I feel like what is
happening to be a waitress relatable oh
my god make it stop rich don't really
need you I'll slide our bill he gets
real little brother a real quick no I
gotta get through here
Marvin says the graffiti side missions
are nice they're very fun
Manzi my brother yeah oh you okay
Delsin no my brother all right my
brother
okay this story try the biotech
I need you I need you right now right
okay yeah
follow emissions the best these are
coming promise me you won't use any of
those tricks okay I wouldn't have been
able to even get to you back there if I
hadn't just promise me you won't do that
Hey Hey I don't really fast I mean he's
the sheriff
[Music]
she's man the latch is melted locked how
the hell he get through I think he ran
through you can do that there's only one
way to find out immediately bioterrorist
fine go control the mobs I'm coming back
with help
see if Betty's in there with the
bioterrorist so we're my favorite things
about infamous Lee's the first one was
exploring around and finding everything
I wanted yeah I have the same thing
someone's side missions always sounds
like fun too even though it's story base
there's a lot more to do yeah we just go
through the door they wouldn't so these
little bins
yeah buddy a human
it's when everything flashes it's always
like a hint you know great vents a
little light on it convenience the fun
thing is it doesn't like hold your hand
at this game it really makes you kind of
like experiment and figure things out
too
they really save that for when you start
learning your abilities instead of like
this beginning part where we all
naturally can kind of run around and do
normal stuff and don't need that ready
don't wanna spoil the surprise
although Stephanie
got to get out of here hey lady wait for
me dolphin I was just trying to create a
diversion I didn't know anybody was in
here did this to me oh you're a conduit
ah Betty I'll explain later but you got
to get out of here now good I'm going
cut until you fix this first oh yeah if
you like chase missions and follow me
I spent most of my life behind bars it's
easy enough to bust out
you just gotta wait for that golden
opportunity when I got my powers hell I
was unstoppable until the DUP caught up
with me yeah
they got a special hold they like to
toss folks like me in figured out a way
to bind us all up so we couldn't use our
powers woman huh nice nothing dead also
meant they had to feed us Walsh says
he'd wipe our goddamn asses that's no
way for a man to live there's no way
they had this redheaded [ __ ] they're
really into needles and scalpels she'll
call what she did make tests
but if you do enough time you learn a
few tricks just gotta be patient sooner
or later they'll screw up they always do
you maybe see something or you hear
something learn things you weren't
supposed to know so when that [ __ ] put
the three of us and that wagon I knew
what was coming
a golden opportunity explains it all
these powers but you know what that
paperclip saw you okay
there's me I thought that was you you
saw it right
they do you be prison she catches you
that's where you're going so I guess
that's not normal wait wait
Betty get out how does she get out she's
crafty old woman she's him till you fix
this the voice acting is actually pretty
good hi
you're a conduit now kid a bioterrorist
even if I gotta go through you like my
healing powers run away
[Music]
James pretty cooler
going anywhere tell you fix this fish
ate something that could be fit and at
least show me how to control it ain't
got Tom do you piece coming
she knows I'm on to her playing
but they kind of get you used to
fighting by you know doing a little mini
bosses I got a get now ain't going back
to curtain cage yeah well whoever's
coming it's coming for you man not me
you've been seen some folks here know
about you talk slot bring a hit I know
no way I'm gonna die in a fish gunnery
let me walk away nobody's ever gonna
know about any of this I am so very
disappointed in you Walter am i right
yeah flush that mean old conduit for you
good job everybody terrorists
Henry Daughtry was a bioterrorist
conduit
he's a word used my traitors sympathize
with their cause you're not a traitor
are you I try not to be you seem nervous
oh yeah he's not playing off my
experience there are only two reasons
for people to be nervous either they're
cowards well they have something to hide
well you know I also get nervous around
pretty girls
get immediate regret oh so good did he
say anything to you share any of his
ramblings about conspiracies no he
didn't didn't share anything that's good
to hear you see we are engaged in a
life-and-death war with these bio
terrorists and it's my job to do
whatever it takes to ensure that we win
that war what it's kind of funny because
aren't you a bioterrorist do why don't
you say anything why would I say that
okay okay okay it's you but
not like this yes
sometimes you have to fight fire with
fire and it's clear now that you are not
a coward which means there's something
that you're not telling me what are you
what are you doing can't do this you
crazy I've got rights and I have the
legal authority to suspend those rights
whenever I feel it's necessary like now
for instance I'll ask again what
happened and I will tell you
I'm told that hurts gosh she's such a
good bad guy have to make you hate her
Betty Betty oh really
still nothing well unless you decide
that you do have something to tell me
I'll go chat with that nice old lady but
you should know concrete is especially
hard on brittle bones and if she doesn't
talk I'll just move on to the next one
the next time it's someone who does so
do you have something you want to tell
me what do you prefer that I move on to
your friends here
do not move choose no oh god it's Betty
I can't it's Betty
it's Betty if it was anyone else
neither whoops we'll figure you'll like
what I said I'm a conduit all right
I caught it a second ago from from that
guy oh you caught it
very funny
so Betty maybe you can give me a
straight answer
wait why would she
yeah I'm told that first you use that
one already
oof I love how they make you choose
between good and bad and that kind of
like dictates what you character is
gonna be I wonder if my powers are also
going to be based off that too because
they also made you a feel for the
criminal a little bit by seeing his
backstory and you were like torturing
him they captured him well it's also the
reason why I had to be like really
hesitant what I said to me what makes
that decision way more impactful too
which is great
wait
crow dream
[Music]
all right so we're back in good health
and by the way you guys if you are just
tuning in to the date to today's stream
we are indeed sponsored by PlayStation
now a service that lets you stream
hundreds of PlayStation games directly
onto your console
it has classic PlayStation 2 and
PlayStation 3 games all the way up to
today's biggest ps4 hits like Grand
Theft Auto 5 Uncharted 4 and God of War
which are available to play up until
January 2nd 2020 also you can download
any ps4 or ps2 games straight onto your
ps4 so you can play them offline at any
time it's as simple as loading up the
game within the PlayStation now app and
hitting download that's what we're doing
today for today's stream of infamous
second son and yeah it's pretty smooth
gifts I bet you guys didn't even know we
were streaming this ok let's see what
we're doing here this is just one of the
titles available on PS now as well yeah
of the many hundreds there's so many
there's like 800 plus games that you can
stream and then like three hundred plus
or something like that but you can
physically download so pretty good
pretty good
oh man you're lucky of that some fast
healing action everybody got body yeah
someone says in my chat they sold their
pews for a few days ago and that's
actually something that I was surprised
to hear because when you told me oh yeah
this is not just something that services
available on ps4 it's also veil on PC
exactly you can download the PS now app
on your PC and also stream and down the
game on your PC which this is pretty
good that's that's like really cool for
me a lot of my viewers - I'm sure all he
needs a little shot controller plug it
in you're good to go
does anyone do this people did she hurt
Wow yeah it looks really painful did
some damage for sure no one could stop
her
oh my god Betty Betty
Dhalsim dear you're awake so the agustin
do this to you yeah did you think I was
gonna rat you out to that ornery trot
tribe besides at the time it seems like
all the cool kids were getting their
legs Pierce he is a bit cold everyone
here but he's the best where comas would
protect our own I would have felt so bad
in my healing no neither should you
can't be ashamed for what you are can't
help it
you were born that way all that matters
about them now you are not one of those
beady eyed bio terrorists who go around
killing people higley pigley oh you're a
good boy
just happen to have smoke coming out of
your fingers Rory's my room this is
smoke coming out of my fingers hey don't
go down that road if you're gonna be
such a buzzkill
I mean I have to go back to sleep
because I need my rest
so that I can get better and get on my
feet again and I can rest now cuz you're
awake
she's too good for us in jewelry I'm
gonna be fine
I think Betty's gonna be the couch
behind a lot of our decisions in this
whole game yeah it's just we don't at
this point Betty exactly what would
Betty think yeah
and she is fall back asleep
right thanks she just sleeping yeah
I want to fall asleep that bad yeah
that'd be amazing we were gonna lose you
there concrete the legs
[Music]
glad to see fast healing seems to be a
part of your new thing speaking of which
the craziness with the hands is that
gone there's no smoking I wouldn't want
to get in the way of anyone's recovery
recovery hey Belson these these people
aren't getting any better they're dying
man you don't know that no but the
doctors who came through here when you
were out they do and they said that I
said the only way those shards are
coming out is the exact same way they
went in what that was Augustine and her
concrete power what a dump our power
concrete is screw it man looks like you
and me are going to Seattle you think
you're just gonna charm her into coming
back here with you come on man I know
you took a bump to the head but two
didn't exactly hit it off last time you
were together Reggie
I did this and I gotta fix it no dammit
Justin you just got back on your feet
look I know you want to help but the
doctors have already said to you the
only way it's getting out is with the
same power I get it which means
you don't actually need Augustin we just
need her power okay now you've lost me
I'm a goddamn power sponge remember if I
got smoke why can't I get concrete yeah
but what if smoke was just a fluke huh
think about it you'd have to go through
what I do you pee guys just to get to
work yeah probably something like that
easy explaining the truck what truck
have a truck aye that's my truck they're
very brotherly dude so good in this all
right I got this whole thing figured out
okay we we hit the town we load up at
the all you can leach condo at power
buffet maybe swing by the space Neal
always wanted to see it and then we're
back home to save some lives
you do realize when we hit the town
there's a fair chance the town's gonna
you know units we got back I live in
Seattle for three years you never went
to Space Needle what is really so I'm
actually a ttle has half a million
people that aren't exactly thrilled
about the bio terrorists that are
already there you think they're gonna
welcome you no but I'm gonna be
different
okay I'm not they're doing what they do
I'm there to save lives I'm gonna be
like Superman be healing the city hero
what you think they're gonna throw you a
parade wake up man so I have to do all
the good stuff if I want to but at the
same time I'm gonna get treated like a
territory right we're gonna fix that's
rough yeah we definitely attack secure
smoke out of your fingertips isn't
exactly normal man just because it's not
normal doesn't mean that it needs a cure
okay van Gogh wasn't normal Gandhi
wasn't normal but people weren't scared
of Gandhi
all right people are afraid of bio
terrorists they're freaks that's
pre-program bull
right well
looks like we walking the rest of the
way what what yeah where you going hey
what does he think we're just going
after that
holy crap would you look at this look
you know if you're having second
thoughts are you kidding there you go so
fast I can't he's not there
this is destruction this is self-defense
man the roadblock was set up to attack
them yet because their bio terrorists
well it didn't stop them and it's not
gonna stop this bad boy either
man this is like a post-apocalyptic
Vegas I thought this must be the
mothership dangerous
oh I gotta feel it fly for a second
hey okay okay balding but you know
that's total game logic oh this is
dangerous and terrifying
let me absorb it don't shoot the drone
down oh yeah definitely new and improved
gelsin this is not improved man we'll
try to fix the problems you already have
yeah add new ones
Agustin is just sitting on her ass I got
a powerup if I'm gonna go toe-to-toe
with concrete Queen hey I'm hoping to
avoid that listen there might be another
way that we can get to Agustin what
other way I have a few connections in
Seattle
right some in the police phone oh no no
no this is not the point where Reggie
swoops in and makes everything all right
this is not your problem to fix it is
mine they're perfect you want to go help
somebody
go save damsel in distress it's not
right fine
we fought fair I can go play Super Cup
okay I will catch up with you in a
minute but don't go anywhere
and for God's sake don't touch anything
I'm gonna touch everything
you're up first little guy oh okay yeah
that could definitely be habit-forming
actually using that they just need to
refill the smoke tank good to go
yeah we should do the trick all those
juicy shards
sort of these shards used for so you'll
be able to use those to unlock new
mobility is our level up a balloon
so they'll of use my touchpad in this
one all I can't yeah I think when you
like grab the shards to you might take a
closer fit at all it also refills your
needs a little bit dude you will not
believe what that BP would okay found a
bus full of relief workers and stuck
trying to convince them to just abandon
the bus all the medical supplies on top
just tell him to hold on I'll get the
bus unstuck
Delsin I know what you're thinking no
dude I just took out a fleet of quad
copters I think I can dig out a bus
their real bathroom yeah oh wow they
doesn't even let me go back I was
thinking like maybe it shows me a
blockade - hold on I'll get the bus
unstuck Nelson I know what you're
thinking dude I just took out a fleet of
quad copters I think I could dig out a
bus this is gonna take forever there's
got to be a faster way all right
oh here we go oh yeah so we collect all
four yeah so we're good to have three
this one this is what my favorite eggs
in the first name is actually like how
you improve your abilities mm-hmm and
they do really make you make decisions
on which ones you like as you start
getting more shots the pill games in -
OH - sorry reg can't hear you over the
sound of my heroics did it
Delsin I'm not huh lost you to hit the
mute button
I got it don't worry there you go okay
the rest of the way is clear we ride
this baby straight into Seattle only got
to wait like two hours traffic
- beki open up and go
what phone dude how do you got
Delsin we got a problem
some of the people on the bus they saw
you doing your super thingy to clear the
way and they're afraid of you I told you
man bio terrorists aren't especially
popular like Rosa Parks and they want me
to sell the back of the bus no they want
you to sit outside the bus but they
don't want you in here right they said
if you come on they're gonna get off
we're not gonna do that these people
have never seen anything like you before
and they're scared right and I can't
blame them give me a second look just
let me run them across the bridge I'll
come right back for you all right it'll
take five minutes
come on man I can't let you on the bus
five minutes
[Music]
it's like raining Grey's have firepower
keep yourself warm
I can understand what the where they're
coming from but at the same time like
and uh here oh you mean like right now
walk to Seattle
oh great it's all part of you character
development
like this prey is what tells you how
crazy some of the power and we're gonna
be later cells like useful information
Nelson I got the eight workers across
the DUP clearing the bridge coming back
for you so that's you there what's going
on hello hey this fast here my stuff is
gonna come in real handy
wait he isn't nope there's no wait I
wonder if it's possible to do a pacifist
run in this game Oh without killing yeah
I know that later on
it lets you like stun them and then you
could subdue them or melee
I guess the city it's fine now
stop hidin
that's pretty cool cinder blastin
all right okay okay I give up okay
decisions I'm easy we're not all yeah so
didn't kill me those he doesn't deserve
to die
well Betty like I know but it would be
so upset she would what would Betty do
right think about that the next time you
guys have to make a tough decision
he'll just happen like he just said
there's like Oh answer me oh my god this
what is a bridge oh is it the five
yep
you know I think since this game count
there's a new bridge to sail so I wonder
if there's only one bridge in Seattle
this point this game
yeah I guess that would make more sense
for this story like the only bridge into
Zi it's not the only way there's a huge
shortcut gotta go save big bro
again they will just lie down
it is very per face
Oh lovely
Corby they worked your magic yeah a new
stuff so the blue stuff is good yes
[Music]
oh yeah
how convenient we need it right now so
you'd stand tough like hard to do this
okay cosmos people coming this is so
convenient how it's all breaking it's
like it's waiting for you across the
certain in the face oh yeah more
abilities
-
I'll be ready ever has
flying yeah
it's like they never like well at least
from what I've played so far they don't
give you like flat-out flying but they
give you a bunch of different tools
honestly that's smart definitely a smart
in the movement in the person presents
really wait Betty
when is the cross smoke - and hover okay
wait wait wait wait Andy can't swim
we might be able make it
eventually you'll be able to power in -
and it gets even more
whatever I can do so like this always
looks like an easter egg up here I feel
like that's become less and less hot
yeah
the bus bus Raji no wait he's not on it
he wouldn't be on
[Applause]
wait that's it help before he falls I'm
coming this is like no music I can read
you got swim yeah I guess I mean if
Elson can't swim yeah regi mustn't ever
his new boots do okay symptoms right
that's not gonna come out of course the
only downside being that nope can't
think of anything this is pretty freakin
awesome really no downside guys over
there now wanna hurt you real bad
added downside yeah now look we're all
we know we may be able to pass you
through their security you know because
you're not a normal viral terrorist no
no no if you mean by normal
you know the Sheep that they try to line
up so that they can probe them no Reggie
I'm not normally did you see what I did
on that bridge I take these guys just
see if we can sneak you through their
checkpoints first all right it'll make
getting around the city a lot easier
okay fine fine do it your way
that's subtle listen just promise me no
one has ever once called you that you
know it's kind of sad we only have 90
minutes and I'm already like terrorists
have the government infused them all
with enough to still do some serious
damage well you have just officially yes
now true so I'm gonna get home Hey
[Music]
how long did you say I was up for one
week wow that means a DUP put all of
this up yep Oh they've kept busy wait so
I was unconscious for one week yeah I
thought I healed way faster than that
okay once we're through
I'll check with a couple of my cop
buddies try and get access to the police
databases the meantime needs you to just
lay low might spook show up with a
bioterrorist okay
yeah this is totally gonna work this is
like a registered firearm I'm a police
officer
everyone just jump over this let me on
his bus won't let me meet his friends
let me out
back at you like all right we got this
yeah like this is not suspicious
whatsoever don't worry oh okay yeah okay
mm-hmm I have a really bad feeling about
this this walk though is this your
casual
[Music]
liberal use of such baby the relation
has been you're not gonna be worried
with a chain that's yeah it's normal
what's a fashion statement this is two
three don't fit rock hell with that dang
your brownie Audrina blow up gangsta
just like that don't tell me how to
fight
[Music]
yeah they can prevent you from going to
him by putting civilians there blasts is
awesome but it will catch anybody in
this I also think like as we get
stronger we're gonna get way more
powerful abilities to we'd be really
careful with this like a chain the best
of things
[Music]
like channeling his inner ghostwriter
oh yeah can you feel the civilians to
get to some extra brownie points how do
you be proud yes some Betty points oh
yeah then I suppose - those are non
Betty boys don't worry oh wait that's
not good that's never a good thing come
in please wait whoa whoa well then
you're supposed to be protecting them
from me so you can still use your - no
matter like how much smoke you have
they tend to put like most chimneys well
let's get out their eyes and slice off
its opening oh I've got you on my GPS
okay so I want to destroy so what
exactly does one of those look like
might kill me or even at all right but
they can see it badass RV with lights
and metal crap on top okay blow out the
paddles got it huh huh huh
right
cool
destroy them over again yeah I guess
somewhere some more Fuego in the free
bed shoot at me no should we know there
shouldn't
[Music]
so these have a shower a second
however one - oh no wait oh it was like
time base didn't even tell me you know
it's so weird - like I feel like if
you're just not in the general vicinity
when you should be at mobile command
post was at the m1 if we're talking
about this stick building I thought
about the actual if you see the map
where it like all red and your star is
in the middle of effort got access to
the Seattle Police database gouge out
their eyes and slice off their ears
I've got GPS mobile command center got
it so what exactly does one of those
look like it should be a large sidewards
and major communication
not bad that's like reinforcement I'm
just like so weird about going to this
red area yeah
we will
you can subdue them for some extra
brownie true but he would be proud and
it will stop him from changing his mind
and like coming back so it's actually oh
yeah those cameras that was out of here
no cameras in our face all right I think
I see it
badass RB with lights and metal crap on
top okay
alright one side down
you know what they said like you get to
go through a thousand of these DUP guys
I was like a thousand that doesn't make
any sense they're over exact you know
they really is a palace up and leave you
look at the Mathers oh yeah I saw that
too that's why I was like maybe this red
area is not the right area to go into
you definitely make a run for the vents
those will get you like out of Dodge
and later on you'll get to level up an
ability that'll kill you the more like
Vince you go and see which
oh you need more smoke
okay that just mean oh boy short and
sweet
be safer there we go
you get up here he has power to suit
some of them like can like jump up to
you oh god okay okay fine fine I was
trying to be nice I was really trying to
be nice again with the quickness fifth
time's a charm
where are draining their resources
though
I'm not sure if any part of this one
right it's like in Betty's eyes you can
also free people from like these little
pins they are but you could also
accidentally blow it up good I love how
they make you actually go to them and
like view them maybe just keep it
talking them normally they're just like
not cool with it I'm working on that
you're getting shot fashion
easy
she was I you must be back before let's
see if we have upgrade here yeah power
up a little bit there are more shards
around after you blew up that thing but
you know big boy over here is chasing
you down but in the meantime if you guys
are just now tuning in with us today's
stream is sponsored by PlayStation now a
service that's lit that lets you stream
hundreds of PlayStation games directly
onto your console it has classic
PlayStation 2 and PlayStation 3 games
all the way up to today's biggest ps4
hits like GTA 5 Uncharted 4 and God of
War which are available to play up until
January 2nd of 2020 also you can
download any ps4 or ps2 games straight
onto your ps4 so you can play them
offline at any time it's as simple as
loading up the game page within the
PlayStation now app and hitting it
download that's what we're doing today
for today's stream of infamous second
son so in case you guys really curious
as to why we were playing this game that
is why and I'm so glad we actually get a
chance to play this game because it's
really fun let's level up our smoke shot
I think it's probably worth it it's
worth leveling those ones up because it
just uses less like energy you have to
re-up on the smoke yeah
oh he didn't even care
got big way and then the minion
no he doesn't okay yeah they didn't do
anything but I respect it yeah I love Oh
every time I go to come toys all right a
lot of AOF a nice low jump in love it
that guy needs our help
wait that guy needs our help I know it's
just an innocent bystander
I'm coming dude changing people's mind
about bioterrorist one civilian at a
time
and then of course this guy over here
down
upgrade points are more important
waitwait
oh we can train smokes I'm too art maybe
not him but maybe things around him okay
that wasn't too bad
wait that's you big actually smart miss
smart why didn't I think of that movie
uh no time to check man I got dupes
coming at me from every direction
yeah great advice
alright
oh yeah it tells you like all the good
or bad things you did
mmm there's a lot more good I could have
done yeah but you only like did one bad
thing and I was on accident accidentally
I'm not sure if Eddie's gonna believe
that all right let me see here let's go
back to see what kind of shards you can
spend everything for you yeah a little
bit more money I was a lot to explore
isn't there whoa okay there really is
pretty fun look at this okay so we can
go more into the smoke shop I think the
smoke shots a good one just that is I
don't know seems good to smoke -
eventually we're gonna get been healing
you can also unlock some new stuff Oh
see okay so this requires Karma level
tuning - mm-hmm sulfur headshots
willaims mug shots what cousin means to
become over time you try yeah no zero
shards that's I think it's probably
worth it as well oh and then you're
saying you do stuff like stunning yeah
getting pretty full intervals that
giving you the option to subdue them I
didn't think how the optin we sneak up
behind you I do the old brother wants me
to fight the ultra mega bioterrorist of
all time with less powers punk I didn't
say that
well yes I shouldn't put it off then
better go straight on to Augustine now
and get it over with
not sure what's gonna happen all right
zucchini Wow that's our closet can hold
a conduit for long but I appreciate your
wanting to lock me up bad man the DUP
wants to be trash this city all the
people are walking hunched over and
nervous looking it's new abilities it's
really nice forgetting farmer oh god I
could be so careful I know there came in
will also be here meat shield apparently
hair they have a really good name I'm
just gonna help
we go this memory I'll see if I can find
this really over here okay
he'll let me walk by yeah I'm surprised
that yeah I'll jump out supers place
Wheatley deserted no fairies going in or
out or anything
get those GC calories
it's a lot of fun I'm gonna like -
around just subdue people it gets real
like Arkham Asylum my farewell oh no
secondhand smoke is bad for you
you really gotta be accurate to Seoul
for headshots we tried really hard
I didn't work he was an Avenue
let's go for the next one this game
still looks so good that is so just came
out in 2014 that's shocking
yeah the cool thing about a station is
there's so many great like single player
games they're really really are
especially with the multiplayer take
over that's been having in last few
years it's been nice to be able to go
back yeah like relive it again and the
new ones coming out
nice man holy DUP guys are in this city
underground like I don't really have to
do this right now I don't want to do
that one person can move around faster
lighter quieter plus it'll make them
under us don't do me a favor and explain
that to him so maybe they'll just give
up why surprise look having some liquor
parkour is much easier yeah I got so
addicted to using the vents in my like
combat I just like go up to the top and
then like drop down on them destroy them
it's so much fun my crazy it's I think
it might be on top the other roof on
your brain
oh oh we got some gang members up here
though oh no it looks like a regular guy
just hanging out maybe it's down below
yeah oh there it is yeah just about
every corner except this isn't their
home Beale he gunned butted you I'll be
back in a second
[Music]
okay so that way is not an option it's
better work oh that's not what I wanted
to do okay now you have these awesome
missiles it's for Betty
we also have a heavy Hamlet to write for
everyone in chat curious about being
able to play this game if you get PS now
yes if you subscribe you'll have access
to this game and also 800 other
PlayStation games from you know PS 2 all
the way to now so definitely worth it
they have subscription plans you know
from one month up to a year there's even
a free trial that you can take a stab at
if you want to see how you like it first
I you know started it up the first time
and was almost immediately convinced
because there were so many games that I
wasn't expecting to see on there and
that were so oh man there's lady behind
him almost even though that shot like a
champ
and we mentioned it earlier but you can
also download the PS now app on your PC
and have access to these hands-on if he
sees you and I think the price for the
full year's like 60 bucks and 60 bucks
for 800 plus games but you're gonna find
stuff you like on your absolutely are
exactly which that's really price of
like one retail game that's really
impressive
it's up there
oh yeah that movements getting crispy
now oh I definitely don't use that chain
enough when I play but I think I'm going
to now because it's so impactful
when you go for the headshots to either
change music any smoke and then you get
to subdue them all it's really nice you
know I keep forgetting not to be close
to them
oh this is my favorite okay okay this
one is so cool play let them round up
that's the bed huh where you want to see
it again I don't think I can actually
he looks pretty dead I don't know I
don't know be able to help him Betty I
used up all the corvy lazy setback pot
anymore no only now he - I'm fine wait
give me more hey the longer you wait
there's no okay that's a lot more blue
I'm happy and no wreck either yeah
you're good now
and he used like the ground pound which
the first time I use it I killed a
civilian all day
[Music]
I don't remember looking like that be
honest doing some renovation spies over
completely okay Delsin I've got some
information on the DUP s--
communications network you have the
street there's a central antenna so they
can coordinate the movements of all the
smaller districts all right any idea
where the central communication thing is
shut up Space Needle okay someone talked
about these side missions earlier and I
want to check these out these are pretty
cool and even what you spray interesting
is good or bad
all right presto we gotta get up
daddy they're so therapeutic and this
guy's just yeah can write the heck man
yeah perfect right but he's got Laird
she was art Wow that is really good
Picasa you know for a stencil that's
really bad I'm gonna be honest okay
looks better at the end oh wow
okay right they always add that final
piece of art that ties it together but I
was thinking the same thing sometimes
I'm like well underwhelming and then
they show it I'm like cool looks great
let's go towards this mission some of
the other side missions I really like
are the find the hidden camera one like
you'll tap you'll like hack into a
camera and you'll see its view and you
got to find it and destroy it and then
like there's a secret agent may show you
a picture of him and you have to find
him in the crowd and and kill him but
not kill the civilians right to it I
like this I definitely went and tried to
like level up a ton before I did this I
want to see it it's like so what a chat
was right those is very therapeutic and
they really like they usually of the
motion control this game a lot it's
quite quite enjoyable sometimes it's
it's rough overdoing it's just enough
it's not for everything
yes a lot better all the shading every
wrinkle in the pan I'm a good guy though
have you ever spray painting in real
life on the wall ah not illegally for
sure I've so and when I went to college
we had this wall of this tunnel at NC
State that was actually you could spray
paint it's not crazy to be awesome
that's true
okay I gotta climb this yep you wanted
your parkour here hmm I don't think it's
that easy
yessuh I think it just boosts you up if
it's the one that's already on top of
the roof yeah
[Music]
hey reg hypothetical you know
theoretical totally what-if question
here but what would be the explanation
for how I might be able to draw the
power from some conduit say oh I don't
know Hank and not others like one of
these doop troopers my god get try
earlier I'm not looking for it I told
you so here reg I'm just looking for
yeah we're like a spider monkey pretty
much we're gonna climb up everything you
know I bet I can help I bet that's fine
okay good I don't know just stops down I
just wanted to scare you just enough
hypothetically theoretically could be
you can only drain powers from a conduit
who has them naturally a prime cos
[Music]
you're saying we have to keep going read
you loud and clear no push it and next
time don't lie to me okay trust your
brother a little more than that way
I could have round yeah me too I thought
okay you can just jump up tap X it
doesn't like that
[Music]
you're getting the exclusive based on
performances imported taking this stuff
down wait how long has it been since you
were in Seattle Oh at the Space Needle
are you a sight for sore eyes
I don't yeah that's the other thing
he'll literally grab on to anything
this is more like I'm on the observation
deck shields
you're like now I ain't fighting these
Betty be real it's only time to gouge
out the eye of the needle oh I get it
cuz you're on his face and that must be
what holds it all together
have you seen you before
new guy thanks man they got a small army
of it or that they really don't like
other people playing with their stuff
yeah yeah there's this anchor looks like
a total of the antennas in place
yep no suck on this
everyone ways to do it just one less the
fight
[Music]
three
tonight we're talking a brief hey just
let me let me grab this real fast
cool yeah
[Music]
only Betty now
we are going to I'll get her the
postcard still a problem
no that wasn't you I think he destroyed
his home
[Applause]
why miss while they dodge that too
all right think you just got big boy now
not too bad we gotta destroy the anchor
school things early
it sounds a little bit right there yeah
that's not an anchor and a winch yeah
yeah I don't think this is gonna cut
nothing bad ever came to getting new
powers
since all these cables probably
more power to
[Music]
let me get something really strong get
something probably
oh yes something yeah five seconds ago
and we top people
good take home room that wasn't so bad
orbital drop
by so doing he's going to break this
week once you get a full street press
okay so I need to do good things
yeah they gave you a couple people yeah
isn't that better that's actually super
hey hello I lost you
did you read me I'm getting nothing sir
you nothing outside our immediate area
[Music]
streets take it easy a few streets in
the immediate vicinity do you pee still
owns the other 98 percent you knocked
out their comm center okay
it may be deaf they're not dumb you know
what they say the journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single kick-ass tag
yeah you could pick your tag now Oh
Chinese people I think the top right
yeah it feels like we're trying to be
the good guy hey reg you see it from
down there hell is that that's not one
of the three who escaped oh alright yes
guys well it's the start of a great
story indeed that's like just the
beginning and that is actually gonna
wrap up today's stream which was
sponsored by Playstation well we have
the PlayStation now you can stream
hundreds of PS for ps3 and PS to games
directly to your console or PC with new
games being added every month in
addition you can download any ps4 game
in the service on to your console to
play it anytime
so with hits like fallout 4 NBA 2k
Mortal Kombat X and rocket League
there's a lot to play so you can learn
more at PS now.com and of course thank
you guys so much for tuning in it was a
blast
thank you giant waffle extreme here and
you know despite travel issues still
showed up to place we made it the second
son it was a fun time and hope you had
fun too thank you guys so much for
tuning in and we'll catch you guys later
peace out
you